[Music]
again quick reminder thursday september
24th at 7 p.m we're going to be doing a
live show
are you garbage at the punch line in
philadelphia pennsylvania come and check
us out
yeah guys it's going to be a good show
we're going to do a live stand up and a
live podcast with special guest
mike rainey from dadmy podcast so check
it out get your tickets
now yes sir hey gang it's your old pals
uncle hank and kippy just want to thank
you for tuning in to
ru garbage yeah guys make sure you
subscribe
that way you get the episode as they
come out you can also go to
gasdigitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and
hd streaming do it yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
glorious day here a beautiful
fall day here in new york city alive and
well
in the heart of the east village at the
gas digital studios
we're coming at you feeling [ __ ]
fantastic
yeah my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me
gang you know him you love him he's the
brains behind the operation
let me tell you something the next time
you're reaching for a best pal you go
ahead and make it a kippy he tastes
great he's lost filling and now
available in an eight pack
so check that out give it up for kevin
james ryan everyone hey what's up gang
thanks so much for tuning in as
always we appreciate it um couple of
things couple points of business up
front to get
uh out of the way uh just announced uh
okay fully showing off his uh
our the t-shirts are finally going out
everybody you're getting your merch
your garbagio tweet those pics and your
clean living shirts are
being delivered thank you so much for
all the support we appreciate it also
please make sure you rate review
subscribe
on itunes yes full video available on
youtube you can subscribe there as well
also check out people the listeners have
started uh reddit and facebook groups we
appreciate that
go join those if you're on those and the
[ __ ] live show let's cut to the
[ __ ] chase
silly we're coming back [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] the live show where we
make our bread and butter baby
at the punch line in philly check it out
it'll be thursday september 24th 7 p.m
we're gonna do a live stand-up and a
live podcast
with philadelphia's own mike rainey yeah
it's gonna be an outside show they have
it all set up
um that's gonna [ __ ] sell out so get
your tickets baby this thing's got a
motor on it okay
and even if it doesn't we're still
saying it's sold out
it's a sell out at whatever number of
tickets we sell fake news baby
fake news but gang that's neither here
nor there
talk about a [ __ ] rocket ship we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly
special personal favorite here with us
today one of our personal
[ __ ] favorites he is an extremely
successful stand-up comedian and actor
he has appeared on the late late show
premium blend the wild west comedy tour
chelsea lately he has his own comedy
central presents he's been on lopez
tonight comics unleashed
the joe rogan experience this is not
happening
the church of what's happening now and
of course he has his own stand-up
special alcohol principal's office
and as an actor you've seen him in csi
new york beer league weed's
legacy in the cut and of course the
netflix
[ __ ] runaway hit cobra kai
and i got 20 that says that he could
knock out larusso
and lawrence in one [ __ ] shot but the
big question in everybody's mind today
is he garbage i
say no way i say this guy irons his
[ __ ]
underwear give it up for the one the
only bread earns to everybody
[Applause]
dude got you have just funny guy rhythm
you know what
you have like east coast italian funny
guy
it's it's most italians have it from the
east coast
you know what dude i i also got uh the
east coast italian
uh don't know how to use trunk jeans too
i
have a camera i got a better camera it's
not working i don't know how to make it
work
oh you look good you sound great right
yeah we're good
for it you look good buddy thank you so
much for doing the show congratulations
on [ __ ] cobra kai well thanks man no
i appreciate it bro
that's insane it was it was on youtube
for a couple years and then it hit
netflix and [ __ ]
took the [ __ ] off right yeah no i mean
we shot it uh yeah like two years ago
and
well season three which is already done
it's in the can ready to go
nice uh they just haven't wear it yet um
but yeah no it's
it's it's a very very uh you know
pleasant surprise
i didn't expect to be this you know this
big you know
dude they they just they did it so well
man like it makes fun of itself it does
the perfect tone
it [ __ ] has the nostalgia and it also
[ __ ] you know it
it like reinvents karate kid it's like
was he the [ __ ] bully was he not the
bully
you know [ __ ] johnny lawrence was
getting [ __ ] iced by his parents so
that's why he was acting out
the whole thing's [ __ ] great man i
love it
yeah thanks man i mean um you know but
you know everybody forget
too that daddy he was a kid there they
were just kids
you say like you're his cousin coming
into court i love it
[Laughter]
he's a teenager somebody's clipping his
girl you know what i'm saying my cousin
it's where i come from dude [ __ ] cook
out on the beach trying to relax play a
little soccer all of a sudden this punk
shows up with a [ __ ] red hoodie going
after
elizabeth's shoe on me you know what his
jersey attitude
i'd love to see elizabeth on the show
man i [ __ ] love her
adventures and babysitting that was it
for me
good night you know she's she's in that
show uh
the boys yeah season one she's [ __ ]
great in it too
and i know so do you think you're
garbage you said you do but be honest
i mean you you keep yourself well
together
you know what i mean you look sharp you
act sharp
what makes you think that you're garbage
you know i don't know what what the
criteria is so
let's go
criteria is one of the criteria but you
should not say the word criteria yeah
he's pointing at us with two fingers
what's the criteria
now which one's the fat one huh
but now the only thing that i can see
getting you on is
you're you're a child of the 80s you
were an 80s kid
yeah absolutely yeah that's a tough look
there's a lot of fashion there's a lot
of things that went down in the 80s
that are tough that's tough to overlook
but i say now no way but we're going to
find out we're going to have a little
fun
we're going to see what's up and what is
the what is the origin story of bret
arts you're from you're from jersey
right you're a jersey guy
um i'm both i'm more south florida but i
was raised in jersey like you know i
uh i went back and forth
so tell us this story so where did you
grow up
uh in passaic new jersey and
and so back i went to high school down
here in fort lauderdale i'm in florida
right now actually
do you live down there full-time or
you're just there for the for the
pandemic
no i i uh i just bought a place in vegas
so
uh
she's in the other room right now brett
keep it down in there
that's the best thing about the pandemic
it's like all these [ __ ] you know
all these established comedians are
broadcasting from like a closet in their
[ __ ] mom's house it's great
i love it does she still hook it up did
she hook the food up make dinner
breakfast the whole nine yards
yeah yeah i don't know what it's like
mom's in breakfast i don't know what it
is man
the trashier yard the better the bacon
egg and cheese is i don't know what but
my mom puts out a [ __ ]
michelin star bacon egg and cheese in
the morning
my mom's think she makes these pancakes
man i don't know how she does it
um and they're phenomenal they're just
amazing yeah
that's too good so brothers and sisters
what was the deal what'd you what'd your
dad do what'd your mom do and what was
with all the uh the back and forth
between
florida and jersey
oh he froze up are you there yeah yeah
you're good now
yeah um yeah well it's it's
already qualifying for trash well fort
lettermail i mean we could have wrapped
it right yeah the two the two places
you've spent most time is [ __ ]
passaic new jersey and
fort lauderdale they are two tough
places to come out yeah we're just doing
this for ad time at this point
it's just [ __ ] called emotions
but i still say no all right well um
background wise uh you know a single mom
okay i had a brother oh i had a i was a
middle middle child
and then my mom remarried i had a
stepfather later on and i have a
step-older sister and a step-older
brother
okay and is that why you guys moved down
to florida
um actually back to jersey and then back
there they
we went back and forth gotcha it was
both it didn't it didn't matter
yeah they remarried my mother remarried
in jersey though
okay what kind of house is we talking
about in jersey and florida
apartments condos single family homes
what's what's the neighborhoods
that you're growing up like i grew up in
mostly apartments when my mom remarried
with my uh
well my stepfather we had a house like a
house up there and then moved down here
and then uh apartments mostly my life
yeah yeah
come on okay i'm laughing right now i
know i'm checking boxes
yeah yeah i feel like two [ __ ] feds
you're not giving us anything
you're being real vague you're like you
won't get you i can't get you nailed you
down for a timeline
that's the italian dude yeah you only
you can't you
you can't hammer that hammer down
answers he's like maybe i was there
maybe i wasn't what'd your mom do yeah a
little bit of this a little bit of that
you know
she uh my mom uh you know she raised
this mostly on her own so
got the three of us most of my life you
know
so but um yeah it is definitely
definitely apartments would be would be
the answer did you start working at a
young age
yeah i've been working i mean literally
i've been working since i was like
10 11 yeah what was the first job
uh doing uh construction grunt cleanup
when i was a kid
at ten landscape yeah eleven yeah was
that always
i was on dude i'm not joking man i've
worked i've worked my every
every day i've never not worked i mean i
started when i
i started when i was 12 but not [ __ ]
construction at 10. that's hardcore well
you just blew it up you're like a
[ __ ] busboy for the uh skilled labor
and then uh but my first official on the
books job
was 14. i worked at a skyline
i was i was a skyline chili i worked as
a cook
damn chilis is that what you said why
line chili it was like a uh
fast food you just threw the [ __ ]
chili in the eater
you know he's out back smoking and
saying yeah it's hard work he's like
talking to the cocktail wait
shepherd's showing the waitresses you're
not
showing the waitress is your knives and
[ __ ]
it's awesome ah that's too good all
right well let's get in a little [ __ ]
are you garbage here uh brett we're
gonna ask you a series of questions
um answer them open and honestly is the
best of your ability
um if it sparks anything you know please
uh feel free to elaborate
you're talking to two scumbags from
philly so you're in good company here
all right i know don't worry about it
i had chili before i came in here so
that's where we're at
let's kick off some basics so you moved
around a lot but we're gonna start i'll
center on
high school you said it was in jersey
right or was in florida a lot of that
plantation
okay all right so you let let's kind of
focus around that time around florida
you're living in an apartment
so uh what was the name of the street
that you that you that you lived on down
there
yeah well let's see uh this is tough uh
there's it's a court it's like 15th
court or 33rd court or something like
that
that's not too bad now is this is this a
condo community
no it's apartment complexes it's an
apartment is there a swimming pool
yes of course every every uh complex
down here has a swimming pool
okay so it's got a little karate kid
kind of vibe
coincidentally enough correct enough
over south florida it's the complexes
everywhere you go
is it's got a pool and um you know it's
it's a lot of
there's a lot of apartment complexes
down here just put you like that
got like the florida project like that
movie
i didn't see it but uh i'm sure for sure
if it took place in florida then yeah
yeah okay
sorry i was reaching on on the 2017
william defoe indy there i apologize
i'm trying to get something out of him
he's ice cold on us
i'm not cold i'm just asking you
that's fine i love it go ahead
all right what was the name of the
grocery store that you guys shopped at
growing up
yes um
well there's food town when we were in
jersey amp
um amt is not bad food town's pretty
tough afp is not bad
yeah aap uh but food town
publix and wind down but mostly
you know public [ __ ] i've never been was
it nice is how where's that fall do you
feel like would you shop at a publix
today
where do you shop now compare that by
the way what i think is hilarious like
where did you two grow up
[ __ ] grocery store and i think having
a pool and an apartment complex
we're garbage dude we told you we grew
up in the suburbs it feel like we're
like it's
suburban with suburban white trash
through and through
where the [ __ ] did you do there's still
there's still an unfinished shed in my
mom's backyard that started that started
construction in like 88. yeah we're not
judging which is this is the criteria in
which we determine
whether someone else is like if you went
to a kroger
if you were you shopped at a kroger or
if you were like oh yeah we used to get
groceries out of sunoco
you're [ __ ] trash now i'm sure now
where do you shop now out in l.a
you go to ralph's you trader joe's
yeah ralph's you know whatever is
convenient man see that's
yeah but the down here is publix is like
if you're really uppity you go obviously
to the whole foods or there's another
one now
called the atari or amari or some [ __ ]
but
um the average person uh goes to uh
you know the trash shops at publix
because
whoa whoa whoa publix is all class hey
shut up you
oh okay
[Laughter]
that was the owner of publix
we got ad time with him yeah
i was a i was a bad boy there too when i
was like 16.
okay the best i was a bad boy at an acme
up here and
dude the people that you work with at a
supermarket when you're a kid
you work with some like the dudes in
like the meat department and [ __ ] those
are some like those those guys can get
you ketamine after your shift and [ __ ]
like that
yeah if you're over 30 work in there
there's some
infants but you always got like that
young hot 19 year old girl at the bakery
dude we were just talking about that
yeah
it was pretty cool man i mean to be
honest with you i i worked there
basically through the holidays but i
also worked there
to um i used to sell [ __ ] like in school
candy and stuff like that and i was
always
clipping [ __ ] from from the uh from the
back that's fantastic
i used to grab bags of that [ __ ] i was
always finding a way to
to uh to hustle and make extra money
a little extra scuttle you know yeah
dude i had a body when we worked we
worked at the acme my buddy
he was in the produce and he would sell
weed out of the produce department he
would be like yo believe the money under
the apples the weeds under the [ __ ]
bananas or whatever and they'd be like
dime bags and [ __ ]
dude listen man down here when i was in
high school down here everything was
drunks everything i mean
everywhere you it was in the 80s so it's
like cocaine
you know and it was just everywhere
everywhere so uh
you know i didn't really i didn't i
never touched anything like that in high
school
you know but it was everywhere man
yeah damn that had to be wide open down
there the coke must
uh like i used to sell like fake
steroids to kids
what the needles no you get you get a
little uh vial
you fill it with western oil oh my god
that's insane dude that's
so funny we used to uh
used to always always hook up but if kid
would you know
they don't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing
you know but yeah when i was when i was
a teenager
that's great wesson oil that's he didn't
get any bigger in his cholesterol
through the roof
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's like
that's dude that's something else to
have that mentality to see kids like
wanting
one steroids and you're going to be like
listen listen jerk off
come over meet me in the parking lot
after school
well my friend actually you know really
sold some [ __ ] back then
i mean like we were teenagers and i
would refill the bottles
and then restart them again
uh prima bowling all that [ __ ] that will
pretty much
but like you know he had all that going
on and then my other friend
you know we we we had a lot of uh we had
a little bit of operations going on when
we were kids
dude that's fantastic what was that what
was the whip in high school
well what year did you graduate high
school
in 1990 1990. so 90. so you were right
there man
so what was the what were you driving
around south florida and what was the
car
oh dude i had a uh oh this would look no
i had a ford escort
uh but it was a little mini station
wagon
yep but in the back i had two mtx 15s
oh hold on gets even better
see this is garbage this is what the
show is now you got it right
you're crashing
a clarion um receiver with a pyramid
cue uh fosgate uh crossover
i'm driving around and you know all of
it
was either uh stolen or purchased on
state credit card
[Laughter]
yeah i'm banging uh you know i'm basing
basic music driving around in a [ __ ]
two hundred dollar station
yeah the car's rattling so much the
mirrors and [ __ ] are falling off of it
the glue's coming undone
dude my boy that put it in man he didn't
ground the wire right so
that [ __ ] you know it wouldn't
even start or it would stall if you turn
couldn't put the blinkers on and [ __ ] um
it's not
i get it dude everybody in high school
like wanted a system for sure but the
fact that you still remember
every part of the equipment that you had
in your escort is so trashy you're like
i had the phasers the [ __ ] 215.
that's another thing we were involved in
you know
i'm not joking man i'm not i mean i wish
i don't know if it's funny or not or
whatever but oh it's funny
it's funny i love it yeah we used to uh
you know
we used to take systems and [ __ ] and uh
uh you know
that's like you if you didn't have a i
don't know if you know what a center
punch is
i don't think so oh you guys are nowhere
near real garbage
we're not boosting [ __ ] cars what do
you mean
i thought we got in here
he's gonna try to sell us a license
plate in a minute i'm gonna ask you if
you
it's gonna ask you if you put chili on
your big bike not [ __ ] grand theft
auto
all right so what is it what is it huh
what is it so what's the the pin thing
the center punch is you use that to pop
a window right but it doesn't shatter
out loud but if you don't have a center
punch you can use the top of a spark
plug
to pop it you throw it after the ceramic
and it'll pop the window
and you know you just pop you go in go
in get the [ __ ]
take it out you know you're at night i
mean look you know when when you're
when you're younger you don't realize
how you know
how [ __ ] up that is stupid it is yeah
yeah yeah you know we also had guys that
got forbid
that you know that were waiting in case
somebody came out
yeah yeah somebody yeah if you if
somebody realizes you're running up on
their car yeah
right so there's guys waiting to to take
that guy out if he's going off not not
to kill him
yeah to slow him down at least get out
of there
and then uh you know we we did that when
we were kids and
and um damn did you ever get pinched
doing any of this [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i got uh as a juvenile i
got caught a couple times and as an
adult i got caught a couple times
damn pretty sweet any serious time no
no no no i mean i you know i had a
couple of uh
uh batteries when i was like in my early
20s just for fighting and [ __ ] but
you know other than that as a kid no i
mean you know they let us
they let you go really i mean you know
everything is
wide open yeah that was a different time
back then
they're not going to waste their time
and you know they had a juvie camp well
when i was in middle school
in new jersey i had stolen a car
that's what i love like you have like
the comedian cr slash criminal like
you're partaking in these crowds being
like this is going to be a great [ __ ]
story you know what i mean that's a
comedian bro
i'll talk about in my special principles
office um but it's
the kid that stole it was like i i mean
now i feel like i'm working a bit but
it's
you know my car i'm actually telling an
actual story
he was that kid that you always knew
growing up
was going to go to jail like that one
kid
[Laughter]
no you don't like that kid i know that
kid i got that i grew up with those kids
yeah
he was always outside you know what i
mean it's like a [ __ ]
wind day at midnight and he's just
outside
all the time yeah yeah for sure oh man
those kids were
shifty as [ __ ] never went over to his
house for dinner
if you did you were like what the [ __ ]
but he was like
he looked like a grown man and [ __ ] you
know he had a dick
and a beard and you're like [ __ ] man
yeah
but now i'm kind of doing a bit sure
i know yeah for sure though how'd you
get pitch steal in the car
excuse me how'd you get pinched stealing
the car did they like pull you over
am i freezing a little bit yeah yeah
you're okay
yeah no we um we wrecked the
[ __ ] and the four of us took off
running
and me and my buddy aldi antonio went
one way and then
the other kid i just shouted out big al
by the way shout out to big dude that's
the best name
shout out to alby antonio
went the other way and they ended up
getting pinched
and you know damn they named names
no they didn't roll on us man but um the
the moms figured it out
yeah oh the mom's got used busted
my mom yeah yeah of course that's a good
mom though
yeah it is my mom uh you know she me and
my younger brother were a handful
my older brother would you know he was a
responsible one
yeah and your mom made you go down to
the to the station and turn yourself in
um no it's it's it's not
that the punishment wasn't other than
the [ __ ] massive beating
and all that's good but you know we had
to we had to help work it off
yeah you know
they kept us out of the camp but they
set my other two friends up there
yeah there was that was big when we were
when we were kids they were like uh kids
would like garage out they'd like go
steal beer out of your
garage and [ __ ] or like whatever and
they would get these things called act
weekends where it was like boot camp but
for the weekend like up in the poconos
or something
so they'd send you up there for two days
and you would just like run up and down
mountains carrying like [ __ ] logs and
[ __ ]
the other thing where you remember
bradley's did you guys have bradley's
yeah the clothing store yeah it was like
a department like
yeah absolutely bradley was all right so
we used to uh uh it's so they're so
stupid like that they would
but it was behind the times but like
they would have bikes and they would
have like the flat tires on the bikes
but yet you go over two aisles there's a
[ __ ] bike pump
right so we would still
right by like you know somebody would
look and what kids would run around and
then
my little brother me and my friends we
would jump and ride the [ __ ] right out
of the store man
just take off dude he said that that's
pretty he said they got bike pumps in
the second aisle like they're asking
them to steal the [ __ ] bikes
what do you want me to do i got bike
pumps right there what am i a jerk off
come on you got to lock these things up
like they think that's the way to deter
you from stealing it but there's [ __ ]
bike bike pumps
home run that's brilliant what kind of
bikes do they have good bikes at
bradley's are we talking like a huffy
nah man that's that's also how you know
like i never had um
like you know what i always see like
kids posting about their bikes
like they always wanted this bike like
yeah but we always talk about it
like my buddy getting back to my friend
al he he used to have a bike but i never
had
one and you know when we would take them
you just use them and then get rid of
them
and then uh but i would be like on the
handlebars my brother would be on the
it's like a [ __ ]
i mean you got eight kids on
one kid with the bike yeah i don't feel
i feel like kids don't do that anymore
dude back in the 80s and 90s you could
have six kids on a [ __ ]
six kids on a dyno going down the block
wait kids don't do what credit card
fraud what are we talking about here
we thought about this one too this is
great so
my buddy al al and his brother vinnie um
of course al's brother's name is vinnie
i love it they were typical
you know grease monkeys you know what i
mean and uh
we had taken a mail truck they had a
mail truck
what the [ __ ] no this thing was in a
junkyard it was just sitting there
okay i thought you robbed the mailman no
no no
and they they fixed the mail truck up
and we used to [ __ ] drive around
[Laughter]
we were like 13 [ __ ] years ago i
swear to god man
and you know and your feet's on the
other side
you're like it's an import don't worry
about it this kisses
came over from england holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] awesome fix it up on the mail
[ __ ] man and uh when we were
kids you take it on the street
on the street around the park all over
the [ __ ] place yeah did anybody ever
stop being asked for their mail
or anything like that no no it was it
didn't have the
usa [ __ ] on it you know it was like
offended and all [ __ ] up you know what
i mean
vinnie's mail service on the side that's
so
funny
i just [ __ ] thought remember that man
that's [ __ ] crazy
dude that's funny they're great for
something up in new york or new jersey
now the brothers they have a racing team
oh really what kind of racing
uh i don't know like uh whatever uh
cars cars holy [ __ ] that's not too bad
yeah yeah they they
they fix cars and stuff they've been
doing that since they were kids man
that's the kid that could make a mini
bike out of a [ __ ] lawnmower
yeah dude i had my dude my buddy vinnie
was the same thing he knew his way
around a small engine like it was
nobody's business
little two-stroke ah that's too [ __ ]
funny
all right let's get in a little more are
you garbage here uh i got one
um do you own any sword collections
or growing up did you have a samurai
sword
nah i don't know man no okay um
have you ever had a pet bird i'm sorry i
always carry
jesus and rice
what the [ __ ] is that he's just flashing
steel
that's like something from lord of the
rings too
no it's uh it's like i have like a bunch
of these that i used to carry around
do you still do you still carry a knife
on you it looks like chris angel made
this [ __ ]
i know that definitely has a hot topic
vibe to it
came with a lava lamp
wait are you still sticking people
what's going on do you like to knife
people what's the deal
just in case no you just you know
you carry it around you know it's funny
when i got married for like 10 years my
wife
really um helped me get over a lot of
things like it you know
because you know i don't know where it
was by you man and you know again i
don't know if i'm down playing this or
not i don't know
you know and i talk about it you you
grow up a certain way you think
everybody else goes up that way one door
100
yeah yeah yeah yeah there was always
fights there's always something
happening
and it took forever for me to even go
out of the house with with [ __ ]
flip-flops on i would never even wear
flip-flops
when you went out you got to be ready
yeah you got to yeah you got to be good
yeah
and the funny thing is is like things
never really popped off like that all
the time
you just you're always on high alert
thinking something well
but then the one time it does you're
there you're ready yeah
yeah that's why if you ever see a guy
with tim's tied up you know he's right
he's that dude means [ __ ] business
if anybody you see a dude on the subway
with his tim's tied to the knee
[ __ ] steer clear of him yeah we i
wouldn't say but
i wouldn't say by any stretch of the
imagination who grew up like that you
definitely grew up tougher and that
sounds like a tough town
and tougher times but there's well i
would feel this too like because i was
raised by
my single mom like me and my little
brother we we always we lived in a
really rough area at one point
and you know a kid like we i would set
up
like in the house like if you we'd have
a bat here
god forbid somebody broke in you know
what i mean because we were going to
protect
her and like we used to have to go to
the laundromat as a kid i don't know i
mean
this is definitely going to qualify me
for some kind of garden
but uh my mom has to go to the
laundromat you you follow you know i
would follow her
at like seven or eight with you know
just making sure nobody's gonna [ __ ]
with her
and then and when you get i don't know
i've ever been with laundromat
especially in like florida
oh [ __ ] star wars canteen
the champagne is not great
it's built everywhere i i think that
that plays into it as well you know i
was always as
you know i was always worried as a kid
well i think there's a thing too when
like violence is semi-normalized like if
you grow up in a place where like you
see
they see fights and when fights are a
possible
outcome of you know of engagements or
like of
conflict which just becomes normalized i
remember i was [ __ ]
took my cousin golfing one time and like
this dude hit up like this dude like hit
up on him a couple of times
and he's like you know he like [ __ ]
hang sheetrock and then all of a sudden
he's like
they're like toe-to-toe in the fairway
and he's got his club my cousin's got
his club over his shoulder
and he's like the guy's like what are
you gonna hit me with that and he just
goes
yeah if i have to when i'm like oh he's
living in another [ __ ] world than i
am
like just like yeah i will hit you if i
have to do it dude
and you know i think the 80s too when
like i remember one time my school
teacher
uh there were two kids that were that
were you know riffing in the classroom
and then um he just said [ __ ] it and he
and he cleared the desks out
and he said you two right now go at it
and when it's over your full pants and
you know
and he let him fight right in the middle
of the [ __ ] classroom damn that's
[ __ ] awesome
oh you'd be in [ __ ] jail yeah and
kevin and i have a theory that we talk
about now obviously like i said
we didn't grow up anything near like
that but we've both been [ __ ]
punched in the face before and you know
you know grew up around
somewhat violent circumstances
and in the long run don't you feel like
that's a lot of problem with people like
people that have never been punched in
the face that's where as an adult they
run their mouth and all that kind of
stuff
yeah i actually say that if you've never
been punched in the face i don't trust
you
yeah tells me you know it tells me
that you don't have opinions convictions
it tells me that you [ __ ]
that some [ __ ] happened and you ran
that's what the [ __ ] that tells me
what i mean like it and by the way it
doesn't hurt
you know like about that um am i
freezing again
no you're okay i'm good yeah no it's uh
it's
it's good to scrap it out man i meant
look
like i guess it was different times i
was telling my mom this it's like i
never
really realized i would be alive to see
a whole different
america like you know when your
grandparents would say that
and then you're like i mean dude
everything everything is [ __ ]
different
yeah and i don't know if it's for the
better i mean
i you know i i don't i don't know but
to i think you should always just it's
only skin that's what used to say as a
kid it's only skin
knuckle it up it's all and then don't
[ __ ] about it and you know yeah no for
sure for
i we like that's how whenever there was
an issue
on the street that my dad would be like
yeah you're gonna like
that kid took your baseball bat or would
it like go get it or like you know go
go [ __ ] go you gotta go get it like
you're not coming back in the house
without their baseball
bit or whatever wait till he's sleeping
and then steal his dad's stereo
i don't think so yeah i lost
i lost the 20 minute but i got a i got a
system for two grand
dude actually i think that's just the
time too back then man
you know because all the systems like
right now
every car has a [ __ ] phenomenal
system
sure it's in there yeah but then i meant
like stealing stereos you know what else
kids used to take the hood ornaments
like yeah
yeah they were big and then uh
you know that that type of stuff
everybody at least where i'm from
everybody
did that yeah for sure absolutely yeah
all right [ __ ] love it all right i
want to talk about some uh
some traits here some things you do it's
something that's been a hot button issue
on the podcast over the last few weeks i
want to see what your thoughts are
and this is where i lean to him not
being garbage in his mannerisms
yeah yeah yeah like you he right you as
with most attacks they run a
tight ship you know what i mean you're
very you have a lot of convictions about
what is trash and what is not you carry
yourself like most
most italian men carry themselves like
[ __ ] gentlemen you know what i mean
so that's where i think i think you're
all glad you probably came from but you
can't
obviously came from a tough background
you know the launch of the [ __ ]
bodyguard
to the laundromat's a tough look for
sure but i think you're [ __ ]
probably all class now today's episode
is brought to you by sheath
underwear sheath makes the softest most
comfortable boxer briefs i've ever worn
i literally have them on
right now if you're sick of boxers that
are too loose or briefs that are too
tight
sheath is for you here's what sheath
does that is unique
it's a stretchy fabric made out of
moisture wicking technology
it feels silky and keeps everything cool
comfortable and
in place baby which is important it's
perfect
it's a perfect underwear for working out
plus the most unique thing about sheath
underwear
is that they have dual pouches that
keeps your man parts separated
which prevents them from sticking
together which is huge when you're
working out or being in hot environments
or if you just want to make a little
fall activities a little more enjoyable
you know what i mean big man
i hear you buddy and you know what'll
make pumpkin picking a little more fun
i'll tell you this right now making sure
your balls aren't stuck to your thigh
because i've made that mistake before
apple picking pumpkin picking
i remember last year cutting down the
christmas tree my nuts were sticking to
me like a [ __ ] piece of old [ __ ]
bologna
but i'll tell you what chief underwear
can make that happen for you
make you feeling fresh and clean no more
chafing
no more gross ball sweat nothing but
comfort
and support now for some of you that
might not be interested in separating
your man parts i still recommend chief
all right
i'm a little guy i'm not gonna lie to
you i'm not showing off i'm not the
toughest kid on the block
i wear them normal all right you can
just wear like any other pair of boxer
briefs
and they're [ __ ] incredibly
comfortable it's unreal and one more
thing
they look good i have never looked
better sexy air of underwear
dude i'm telling you what i put my
sheaths on i got the camo ones
oh i feel like [ __ ] machine gun kelly
walking around my girl takes a run at me
i see you laying on the couch gang let
me tell you something i want to finish
this out strong
all right if you're packing like a real
big man you're packing like a real big
man don't worry about that just go to
sheath underwear and get a pair of the
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
own
and if you use promo code garbage you're
going to get 20
off your order that sheath underwear dot
com use promo cart garbage
to save 20 now back to the show how do
you feel about brushing your teeth in
the shower
um you know listen it depends and
uh i'm not a big if you want to know
this is where it's going to get really
really really
crazy i i have i've never had a cavity
in my life whoa
and what i do is i i have a whole system
when i brush my teeth i have a waterpik
guy's got a water pick holy [ __ ] and
then
i do my um the listerine or whatever and
then i would do a fluoride rinse
at night before i'd go to bed see
another
see that's f i don't care how many cars
you stole
that's [ __ ] clean a water
but okay so he's not a psycho well you
keep
well you keep the toothbrush you don't
keep the toothbrush in the shower when
you leave
right oh absolutely not yeah there's
adam there's savages out here doing that
a lot of people you would be surprised
what's that
animal
[Laughter]
yeah for sure dude for sure [ __ ]
great
go ahead kip um let's see
have you ever worn a wife beater in
public
uh i'm florida absolutely okay florida's
a little i forgot about florida okay
i'd like to hear his opinion on the uh
on the jersey ask him the jersey
question
okay so you have to you have you have to
wear one of the following right you're
going to a wedding
and the only options you have are sports
jerseys
right like you have a baseball jersey a
hockey jersey obviously you would not
show up to a wedding
dressed in a jersey the gentleman that
you what do you think the classiest of
them all is if you were a
gun to your head you're end up in a bad
situation that's all you got
you got to wear one what are you wearing
out of all the professional sports
okay first off i'm going to take this
another level of my
insanity uh i don't wear football
i don't wear jerseys i don't put another
[ __ ] man's name on my back i
agree i agree i don't do it either i
know you're like he's old enough to be
my grandfather
but not a dude that's either my age or
younger are you hi
i'm wearing some 19 year olds yeah yeah
yeah you're not wearing a mellow jersey
but if you don't want to want to a
wedding to look
like the least of an [ __ ] you know
what i mean like what's the you won't
have to go
a baseball jersey because you could put
a tie under it
because it buttons up it's got to be
like like you're at your hall of fame
induction ceremony
i've never heard that answer that's
brilliant great man that's brilliant
have you it compartments and it comes
down so you could have if that's
why
oh jesus we're having a good time i
[ __ ]
love it have you been to a wedding
where somebody no or something
no where somebody wore a jersey no man
really i'll be honest with you any
wedding that i went to if somebody
showed up in a jersey baby
have you ever seen anybody wear
something they shouldn't have been
wearing to a wedding where you're like
get a load of
you know like a short sleeve dress shirt
or something uh
oh you know what i will say this when my
cousins got married their
their their family side the other side
it's always the other side where you're
like yo
where did you [ __ ] animals come from
this guy was stacking his beers
and you know and then my side of the
family somebody went over to him and
said listen
you know you're off the tables you know
you're embarrassing yourself and
everybody here
you know and he didn't realize it but
you could tell
he was stacking the beers like a [ __ ]
pyramid
then only the italians will speak for
everybody
when they say you're embarrassing not
only yourself
but everybody everybody at this baseball
game
there's a lot of good people around here
what are you doing they're trying to
this guy's a [ __ ]
treat me like i'm a half a jerk off over
here dude
everybody here it's always it's always
the other side of the family where
you're like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
yeah it's not
it's the people marrying it yeah but
it's usually the guy or the girl that's
marrying in is typically you're like oh
okay this seems like a normal person you
meet them
but then you meet their aunts and uncles
and cousins and [ __ ] and you're like
what the [ __ ]
yeah this i mean it's very rare you
might get a third or fourth cousin and
an italian-american family but
you don't see that [ __ ] not in our fa
and by the way i'm also german i mean i
was raised my mother
sicilian and i was raised in a sicilian
you know background
so there's a lot of pride and you know
two things you should have pride in is
in your work and your appearance you
know how you carry yourself that's what
my grandfather would say that you know
it's your character's everything
yeah like i i'm still like i got i get
my nails done i get buffed
i knew it i'm telling you my
grandfather's and they all did that too
i mean a lot of the gangsters used to do
that [ __ ] all the time yeah for sure
you know in philly you saw you saw the
guys that that had the suits on they
always had the nails done and you looked
at them and you're like you know that's
a classy guy
yeah for sure dude the italians you guys
do that nice
oh dude there's rules that i have when i
go like you know like if there's women
at the table
they don't reach in their [ __ ] pocket
the stuff that because i was very
believe it or not i was very fortunate
to be raised
by my grandfather and my stepfather
later on was an older
older italian guy as well like he was 14
years older than my mom and when i tell
you this dude was just
[ __ ] suits all the time you know i
remember one time when we were watching
casino
and remembering and you hear them go
mean guy had scoops like that
like the shoes the [ __ ] like you know he
was so impressed with the suit
yeah you're like oh man
speaking of dinner how do you feel about
splitting the check
what are your rules on that with
with the lady no no say you and another
couple go out let's do
so there's a double date what do you do
i got it this time you get it next time
yeah are you a cash guy are you a card
guy do you operate with both
um now i'm all card i used to when i was
in my point i just used to carry cash on
me
yeah i write it off i didn't understand
taxes when i was in my 20s
and uh you know you know the other thing
is the
see when you you should know but again
we all know because
we're of this ilk what a bunch of when a
group of italian guys go out
okay and you're waiting on that table
whoever's waiting on that table is
probably going to get
at like a 200 percent tip get greased i
used to love that
nice they're going to drop the check one
of the guys is going to pick it up
and then everybody's going to throw in
what they ate as a tip
yeah and that's usually how that works
because he'll go leave and then if i had
like a 40
or whatever i'll throw in [ __ ] 30
bucks and everybody
the kid walks with like almost 100
sometimes yeah
that [ __ ] was always the best back in
the day you get a couple [ __ ] older
italian guys
they're all getting apps they're sharing
the apps they got [ __ ] drinks
there's [ __ ] zambucha [ __ ]
espressos on the table
next thing you know some guy shows up
they get a little [ __ ] come out
and they [ __ ] hook you up with a nice
tip it's great yeah
dude one of my old jokes about uh was
one of my first jokes on a half hour was
about
us yeah you have you have the best
italian cash joke i think
hands down that's i mean when we count
the money like oh
and then when you hit it with like 20 or
whatever whatever the total is is
[ __ ]
home run funny dude but no we fight over
the tab man you know
or the other good there's the other
thing that happens too is
uh like you go out and you go to places
there's this italian um ritual i don't
know like you'll go out
and you'll go to a place where you know
you might get comped
right so when you go in there you're
you're expecting that
but when they offer it you tell them no
sure yeah
because it's like it's damn right but
then when they do it
you tip now as if that was
if we had to pay the tab so it's always
been that
i don't know if it i don't think it's
like this anymore because the younger
guys lost it
there was always that dance like no you
don't have to cop it i'm here
you know and then there's things that
you do like you don't let them know
until after you pay
and then they're like okay you know
you're it was always this thing that you
showed respect i can't explain it there
was nothing
i know exactly what you're talking but i
waited tables up until a year ago i was
still waiting tables a year ago
and it was at a [ __ ] burger place and
nyu
and let me tell you something that [ __ ]
is going away quicker
than anything they're [ __ ] arguing
over all well i only had this and you
add that
they [ __ ] are six kids they hand me
12 [ __ ] credit cards
i remember exactly what you're talking
about that fighting over the check thing
i think about that when i was a kid and
like when i see that now it like warms
my heart
and it's always like somebody like our
parents generation yeah i got it i got
it
the [ __ ] the the you know my uncle
[ __ ] just like listen don't say
anything
i'm taking care of the check order
whatever you want or him and my dad
fighting over it at the end of the meal
or the [ __ ] coolest move is one of
them would get up go to the bathroom
bang bang bang and come back okay we're
ready to go
that's [ __ ] class that doesn't exist
anymore and when it does it's beautiful
to see
yeah i had to do that a couple of times
but you know i'm gonna i'm not gonna
one-up it
but my uh my my godfather my my uncle
you know guy i looked up to i i he
pulled a tony soprano when i picked the
checkup one time and he thought
oh yeah they'd get mad at you you
[ __ ] slapped me
what yeah he's you know in a lovely door
in like a loving yeah yeah
like what the [ __ ] are you doing you
know and he the look in his face he was
really upset
he's like i appreciate the gesture you
know and he was really upset about that
but
we joke around about that now like he
smacks me in front of like we'll go
that's real guinea [ __ ] i love it we'll
go out
and and i'll say um and we'll go to the
home for this right we do this a lot and
he'll stand there of course it's safe
but it's funny to both of us
and and i'll say hey uh yeah i'm gonna i
want to make a reservation you know can
you put our name in and i'll give him my
name
and he'll go wait you don't see me
standing here you're gonna put your name
and then oh i'm sorry and then he'll
smack
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm like i'm so sorry you know
and then we act like it's normal but
it's like a stupid andy kaufman thing we
do
that's too funny that was a waste of
[ __ ] a minute
no no no no it's all class baby
ah well he holds himself to that stand
dude i got one
i got one when was the last time you
were at an olive garden
i [ __ ] that i don't know man
i think uh when i lived in l.a one time
we
uh we went to one me and my wife at the
time ex-wife
um it was uh just to get the soup and
the
sap yeah there you go awful
how do you feel about cash back you get
cash back when you make a purchase
he means if you go to like ralph's or
whatever and you bought you're checking
out they go do you want cash back and
you take
you use it like an atm um i've done that
before a couple of times but you know
that's when i'm
when i'm when i'm going somewhere and
i'm like [ __ ] i want but i need it to
tip
yeah it's true i got a greasy guy come
on
you know i'm saying if i'm short i'll
have them take it out and break it up in
fives
for sure you know what i mean who do you
tip where's where's your standard on
tipping
who gets a tip you leave something for
the cleaning lady
absolutely always whenever whenever i
stay in a hotel because i don't have
them touch my room
at all because i don't want people in
there i get steeped out you know i guess
class that's a glass family that was
clear
guys clipping before i was in there um
so i i don't that freeze
yeah yeah you're good now okay um i
don't leave
um like i don't leave towels around or
anything like that but at the final end
i'll leave a five or
ten after i you know i'll put it on
there for her
um my biggest and my best move and i and
this is again i suggest this to anybody
whenever you go out to eat the the the
guy that brings the bread in the water
just it depends on the restaurant a five
can usually do it but if it's a higher
end
give him a ten right out the gate
because i used to wait tables all the
time
okay and this is there's two things in a
nicer place you got the front waiter and
the back waiter and they pull the whole
thing
that guy always ends up getting [ __ ]
yeah yeah right
number one but number two you give him
that five
you're gonna see [ __ ] showing up on your
table that won't be on the bill
yeah yeah yeah he's johnny on the spot
with the [ __ ] extras
so once you give him that like if you
give him a five or ten now you know what
he's putting it in his pocket so it's
going somewhere good
and then you can say to him hey can you
get me a diet coke or hey can you get me
something
and he's like sure now you know [ __ ]
that you rob the restaurant [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] yeah yeah he's not yet
he don't give a [ __ ]
he'll start giving his sodas and [ __ ]
and extra bread he'll
do everything good and you know and he
he probably
you're gonna get that you know robbed
anyways from him from the from the
scumbag
uh meth addict front waiter you sure
yeah yeah yeah
i know man uh i love the systems the
hierarchy in your head is
[ __ ] [ __ ] beautiful it's so dude
when you go to i'll tell you this works
almost all the time i don't know how how
the
car washing places are about you but i
was just gonna ask you about it
you get it you get a basic wash but
and you go give the [ __ ] guy that's
drying your uh
your car and then you tell
hey man put the [ __ ] on the tires and
and then and then
you know so so you go right to him ah
it's pretty good
nine out of ten times i would say 99.9
percent they'll do
this he's going to put the armor on
he'll wipe he'll even offer to wipe it
in the car
you know what i mean now it's not bad
the way that works so you get a basic
wash for say
15 bucks right all in is almost 30.
yeah so it works or whatever right you
pay that
you give him i was gonna tip him five
anyways so for an extra five now
you've just saved yourself another
almost ten bucks
yeah i'm giving it to him but everybody
eats everybody enjoys
sure yeah it's a family party family
style
everybody wins in these situations do
you always get the tires done
without fail absolutely i got one for
you have you ever gone to one of the car
washes where you spray it down with the
hose
like you do it yourself
that's the only one i went to
yeah yeah i was one of those losers that
went away to community college
[Laughter]
what do you mean it's a tallahassee the
tcc and the only
washing thing they had there was that
thing those are for like cleaning out
dead bodies that's for like getting
blood out of your trunk those things
you all those open up at 10 p.m though
yeah those things are real shifty in the
middle of the night
you're washing down the [ __ ] escort
[ __ ] 2 a.m
uh i got one for you too because yeah
you you travel a lot you're a [ __ ]
you know you're a [ __ ] road dog do
you will you get
food when you're traveling will you get
food in the terminal and take it on the
plane and eat it
nah [ __ ] yeah i know it's like
it's it's it's inconvenient it's just
not comfortable
um i'll be honest with you i'm able to
keep my weight off
uh because i'll do intermittent fasting
and the days that i'm traveling
i won't eat in the airport uh i'll get a
black hole
and you know and i'll travel that whole
day and then if i get to the hotel at
night if i have to be there to do press
the next day
i'll have my first meal like after i'm
settled in at the hotel or if it's at
the club
i'll get something uh right before i go
up okay
but that's usually i think it's a real
trash move to like you're you sit down
and you know
like [ __ ] 31f and then some guy next
to you just pulls out like a [ __ ]
bear burger or something you're like
yo what the [ __ ] i gotta sit next to
these fried onions the whole [ __ ]
time
it's awesome
and that little ass he's trying to make
it work with tiny napkins and [ __ ] it
just can't do it
you take your shoes off on the plane um
yeah we'll see yeah but not it's my feet
like i don't i'll never show
yeah everything's calculated with you i
feel you're very calculated
every move every gesture everything's
calculated
i have the dark really feet and all that
[ __ ] you know
what about a full-size pillow on the
plane you do that no
[ __ ] dude those people look like they're
going to [ __ ] sleep away camp it's
like dude what are you doing
it's a two-hour flight let's go act like
a [ __ ] adult
yeah you got my pillow at home
[Laughter]
ah speaking of pillows uh
something that we've been uh throwing
around here for for a week or two
uh is uh how many pillows do you use to
sleep
how many pillow guy are you the more
pillows the more garbage
oh really yeah i have four like really
expensive nice down pillows that i use
but they
you know i have a pretty pretty big bed
so where do they go though that's the
thing
do you use all four of them you put one
between your legs you do
you hug one i have never ever kicked the
pillow off the bed so this must make me
garbage like i
don't i don't [ __ ] canoodle with it
some of them just sit alone they're not
you know what i mean sometimes
i also like sometimes like if one fold
up the bed i could just grab the reserve
yeah that's all dude in the middle of
the night instead of looking just
[ __ ]
but yeah i got me i would say four
pillows and then
but i would say this might i mean again
if you even have decorative pillows i
guess it doesn't make you garbage
but if you sleep on a decorative pillow
that's kind of
that's for sure dude for sure yeah you
got like
you got like the button going into the
side of your head or whatever you mean
the one with the cover on it that comes
with the
with the with the comforter the
decorative the duvet
that's [ __ ] trash you got the duvets
out
the duvet pillow is your intro
garbage yeah that's all
they've always got a little spit stain
on them for people that use them
yellow stained pillow you ever see those
they're like [ __ ]
looks like somebody pissed on it yeah
dude don't come over my house it looks
like a bag of lay's potato chips right
now
ah it's looking trash what else you got
kip
he bitten him i love this guy all right
let's do some of the basics these are
these are like [ __ ] hot button issues
we asked we asked these to
kind of everybody to wrap it up a little
bit um
these are our standard ones they're very
very uh divisive within
the community uh your let's do ketchup
where do you keep the ketchup do you
keep it in a cabinet or do you keep it
in the refrigerator
uh cabinet until it's open and then i
put it in the fridge
classic how about uh butter is the
butter on the counter is the butter in
the refrigerator
um well i have two butters there's the
butter i cook with
which i cook with ghee and that stays on
oh that's class
but then the one that i put on my bread
i mean yeah we we keep it in the fridge
but then you know you take it out mm-hmm
so it's nice and soft
you know that's the clown that's what
we're finding out is the class that's
the classy way to do it what did your
mom do
growing up did she keep it out uh you
may not know we always she kept it in
the fridge she kept in the fridge okay
i'm surprised by it and you know what
else was a big thing when i was growing
up was
that country croc [ __ ] right
they used to think it was healthier but
that came to be a [ __ ] italian tupper
oh yeah some good meatballs on these
things
after you put the meatballs and give it
to the guests then
you know dude how many times it does you
know how many times i've reached to like
butter a [ __ ] bagel and it's been a
[ __ ] thing of gravy or something i'm
like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god but yeah no we um
that that's the answer to the butter
thing do you [ __ ] with mayonnaise at all
uh yeah yeah i do i like it on a um on a
roast beef sub
every now and then and do you use
miracle whip
or do you use helmands
okay people don't realize miracle whip
is actually addressing
yes i'm aware and it's [ __ ] amazing
on bologna sandwiches i would do bologna
and cheese sandwiches with the miracle
but i don't use it as a regular
mayonnaise just with the
bologna and cheese sandwiches strictly
baloney and cheese
yeah yeah i'll give you that though
cause that's a trash sandwich to begin
with a bologna and cheese sandwich
you're not you're not you're not trying
to impress anybody with a [ __ ] with a
bologna and cheese you know
how about chips on the sandwich uh i
mean when i was [ __ ] eight
oh i still do it dude i still do it
yikes i want to know how garbage
how garbage my family is i [ __ ] my my
wife caught my mom putting chips on her
sandwich like two weeks ago
she was like your [ __ ] mom put chips
on her sandwich like
she was devastated
when i was uh i was doing a theater in
asbury park like maybe two years ago
and i took this kid from l.a with me
right
and just what a [ __ ] abomination this
kid did
all the food carlos i mean he's a
mexican kid from sacramento
um he's one of my dearest friends so my
my very dear friend
owns uh ionelli's on passion in south
philly okay
they've been there for three years he
does the tomato pies
right makes the crab gravy right
we used to live we used to live right
there we used to live right off fashion
cavanaugh yeah
and uh it's you know it's unbelievable
so the first time i take the kid down
he's he's with me at the punch line
where you guys are
and uh wait was that the punchline gig
anyway it doesn't matter
we're we're there so vinnie's like yo
i'm over i'm you know i'm gonna cook for
you know for everybody
dude i mean what a [ __ ] spread right
he's he made the crab gravy we had
cutlets
we had [ __ ] uh uh like four or five
dozen
clams um we he made two tomato pies he
made the [ __ ] um
stromboli yeah yeah
there was [ __ ] four of us okay
four of us and it was just the kid
carlos sits down
and he doesn't like i can't eat this and
that he we had to make him a little bit
of [ __ ]
spaghetti right yeah like buttered
noodles what the [ __ ]
not like regular spaghetti just with a
little [ __ ] gravy
right and then that that was the start
of it and i'm like dude what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you don't know how to eat
right
so then we take them to uh our we had a
sponsors at marukas right
the uh tomato pies in seaside heights so
we go there to get a pie
this [ __ ] kid starts putting [ __ ] all
over it like the chili
you know you're dressing it up and
you're like bro
you gotta [ __ ] paint it the way it is
in its natural environment
sure yeah yeah the way the chef intended
to
yeah yeah yeah so then we took them to
wawa
right don't embarrass me here
dude you got to get a a wawa sandwich
just the italian sandwiches the best
i mean we're hammered yeah where's
putting [ __ ] fritos on
and and my buddy's looking at me like
where the [ __ ] did you find this thing
where i told him we got him a taylor ham
if you call
a taylor ham sandwich all right you know
with the fresh uh the fresh bread
everything said to him if you [ __ ] this
up you gotta eat this now the way it is
no ketchup yet you can add it later
but you know and
the kid was like i don't know if i can
eat it like without the [ __ ]
i go you know what dude you don't
deserve it
you don't confirm anything like it's an
abomination that you that i even brought
you
that's devastating man go in the car
it's like burst said man because uh he
was like dude you know for us like
italian
when we're ordering food it's just
there's gonna be a problem like there's
always a problem
you know what i mean like it means so
much to us and i'm not i don't want to
enhance the stereotype but it's [ __ ]
true man yeah
it's true like like right now i want to
go to philly
so do i so do i man the [ __ ] the crab
gravy you got me
dude you gotta check that place out it's
i know it's unbelievable
oh but the chips you started putting the
fritos and and it's like i don't know
how these
i don't know how people eat like this
yeah i know it's a trash it's a trash
move for sure it's trash yeah
but i'm feeling like eat it the way it
comes i wouldn't do that at a place like
that a place that
that makes that's special for something
but i'll be honest with you i'm not
gonna lie to you
you know what i mean i consider you a
friend i'm not gonna sit here and
[ __ ] deceive you
i might have put a [ __ ] frito on a
sandwich or two in my day
nah dude if you're getting a [ __ ]
hoagie from mcdonald's
from wawa you're playing chips i'm not
gonna [ __ ] go in there and embarrass
myself but i'm just i'm just playing
devil's advocate here
you can't do that i just i just had a
place in uh a place in um
florida it's very very [ __ ]
phenomenal italian deli meets and
you know you just let them make it
that's their job that's what they do
you know like just eat it in its natural
state
you know what it is what it is these
days is as i think the the younger
generation
they're so few and far between of those
places left
yeah you know what i mean that there is
no trust
you know there is no this guy's not
going to make it the way i like it you
know they're
these kids are eating at [ __ ]
starbucks and everything they're getting
sandwiches and [ __ ] starbucks
everything of course they don't trust it
everything's made to order like how you
want it now too you know what i mean
like before would just be like you get
it however the [ __ ] it comes out yeah
there was never any of that when i was a
kid know this
know that you guys who you guys have
right there
right now we're in uh we're in new york
we're in the east village yeah
oh you're in the village i was going to
say you don't live in the city do you
i yeah i live uptown astoria i was going
to say man if you can get to uh uh you
ever go to spamoni gardens ellen b's
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome no good
yeah it's unbelievable like change your
life unbelievable but that's what i'm
saying
there's not a lot of places like that
anymore where it's like you [ __ ]
it's like ben's ben's uh grandma's slice
and on [ __ ] mcdougall street yeah
dude you just don't like
again man this was i'm getting a soft
topic so i apologize
that's all right when i took my wife my
ex-wife i keep saying that into [ __ ]
manhattan one time
she wanted to go to this like a nice
place for a friday night dinner which i
get that they want to dress up they want
to go out
and you know a lot of people don't
realize like you know
i've been a road dog for i've been doing
it 23 years but i've been on the road
hard i'd say about 17
16 or 17 years of that and
when you're married or you're in a
relationship you know eight tuesdays
don't equal one saturday
right well so when you get those
weekends you gotta make it count
and so i brought a work move we stayed
all over i was up there seeing family
and friends you know
a lot of family in brooklyn and you know
um
so we go to the first night we go to
beauty and essex yeah right when that
just opened up
got my buddy called we got the
reservation
and i said i said this night is for you
this is for you
okay but tomorrow night's for me and
we went there you know they didn't beat
you up that bad it was nice touch you
know it's cool you're going through the
[ __ ] music store or whatever
it's great i took her to lmb's on
saturday
we had [ __ ] squares and muscles and
and afterwards i was saying
now you're telling me that [ __ ] last
night
is that what you're going to tell me are
you going to [ __ ] make that argument
it's squares and muscles that's the
[ __ ]
such skinny [ __ ] dude i love it so much
why is it muscle
i uh i love dude muscles are the
trashiest shellfish but they are the
[ __ ] best man
this move that you're not supposed to do
but i do and this is real guinea
this is like getting crash 101. i put
grated cheese on my white clam sauce
but i'll do the outfit i put cheese on
everything
you said that like you make your own
rules you sounded like clint he's doing
you
i'll tell him right now i'll put
parmigiana
on my clam i don't give a [ __ ] who's
sitting at the owner's table
that's so funny but i
nobody's [ __ ] moving get me to
peccarino forget about it
oh my god that's so funny i uh you're
boys with version so i go on the road
with version a lot and every
whatever city we're in we [ __ ] yeah
it does it classy
we go we find like some [ __ ] some
wine bar something we'll go get you know
first sticks he's smoking cigars all the
time and then most people go out to like
dive bars or whiskey or whatever dude we
go out he's
we find like this lounge he orders like
meat and cheese plates and everywhere he
goes
he takes a bite tell me you've never had
something you've never had something
that could happen in your entire [ __ ]
life you never had try this with that
pizza you never [ __ ]
italians always want to prove that what
they're having in that moment is the
best thing in the world
you're not going to find that [ __ ] in
jersey i'll tell you that right now
if you're a guest at anybody and the
minute you if you notice before you take
everybody staring at you before you take
the first bite
[Laughter]
well you take it
[Laughter]
i don't care how many [ __ ] how many
how many cars he's boosted how many
subwoofers he's stolen who you stabbed
in florida
one car one car that the government
needs to know about
now i'm just saying buddy is there
anything you want the uh the folks out
there to know before we get you out of
here you got anything coming up anything
you want to promote
um i i would say that i i i i'm more
garbage than
uh anything but we didn't really get
into the other stuff well so
you've redeemed yourself but you carry
yourself as a gentleman that's where it
is now like you're very you have a lot
of convictions you have a lot of
opinions on how things should be done
that's class people that are like
shopping in their [ __ ] pajamas are
garbage
now dude again and i i think that goes
back to the punch in the face thing i
mean when
when you're not you know if there's no
threat of of you getting dropped
oh yeah if you if you haven't been you
had your ass kicked and you know i'm not
i talk about my act i couldn't tell you
how many i could not i swear on
everything if you asked me to put a
number on it i couldn't tell you how
many fights i've been in my life
but i will tell you this that i've got
about
19 strong losses
[Laughter]
if you've been beat and put in the
hospital and [ __ ] up
and you know you you learn you know you
learn that you know
you got to carry yourself a little
cautiously you know you got
there's ways to do that and and i think
a lot of younger dudes especially they
talk [ __ ] reckless
you know what i mean and there's that
yelling at people and [ __ ] because
nobody's getting [ __ ]
well there's no consequences we got some
guy yelled at us like a couple of weeks
ago we were
outside having a beer smoking he's like
you're not a lot of smoke over here and
like
like made this big scene i'm like he's
never been punched in the face because
if i
go back at him we're gonna it's we're
gonna end up fighting and i'm like i'm
not fighting on this in broad daylight
but he doesn't
in his head getting punched in the mouth
is not uh not a consequence not a
possibility we bitched up pretty quick
i'll be honest
i put that cigarette right now
[Laughter]
but i would have been like you know what
you may be right but you know
that's not how you talk to people like
there was a kid
in sacramento i mean i'm one of those
dudes where i and
you know i would rather fight a dude
that i know i'm going to lose to
and like fight a kid i know i can beat
sure there's no fun in that yeah
unless unless he's just you know needs
to
to be put in check i mean when i was
younger i'm not talking about now now
now i'm [ __ ] you know now i'm
my shoulder hurt i do this but um
there was a kid up in sacramento when i
was just up there that you know you
could just tell this [ __ ] is
never
i meant like just dismissive just no
no type of male etiquette you know what
i mean
and it takes place it takes people back
like i sit there go am i
am i crazy what the [ __ ] happening
here i like how maddie gets it's so good
no this kid and you know he's like one
of those jerk off guys with like the
mustache and the mullet
you know he's just this is how he gets
attention
and you know just very dismissive and it
was me observing more
and until me and him had a little you
know thing and i just told him
you know i'm not gonna [ __ ] smack him
because you know
sure yeah yeah it's like hitting a chick
i wouldn't i was gonna do that
i'm just thinking to myself this dude
has never ever either seen somebody get
[ __ ] hurt
because that'll do it if you see someone
give if you see someone get [ __ ]
tattooed you're like
i'm done i'm good to this day
okay the most disturbing thing i've ever
seen and i didn't even see it because i
was going to my car
because i was just getting the [ __ ] out
of there i i came out of a denny's
and by the way
these two crews were fighting uh these
two groups were fighting
uh in the [ __ ] parking lot right so
i'm getting to my car i'm not gonna
stick around
you know what i mean i don't know if
somebody's gonna pull out start shooting
where
and this dude had a bat and i see it in
the corner of my eye
right the kid runs and you hear that
it was so [ __ ] disturbing if the kid
with the mustache had heard that
oh yeah he wouldn't have a [ __ ]
mustache you wouldn't know how to
[ __ ] talk to people because
you you know you see [ __ ]
she could go from zero to 100 really
quick
yeah it's true i mean well man i don't
know i think that's a
i mean i don't want to sound like a
[ __ ] now but i think it might be a good
thing that things aren't
sure understandable to an extent of
course yeah yeah
oh my god that's too funny just watch
cobra kai and i'll be in uh
where am i oh i'll be in uh naples at
off the hook comedy club
october 2nd through the 5th if you're in
the area cool
very nice buddy congratulations on cobra
kai again it's [ __ ] awesome kippy
what do you got for him out there
guys just like we said the live show
with the punchline yes get them tickets
folks
on uh september 24th 7pm get those
[ __ ] tickets it will sell out
uh and also uh rate review subscribe on
itunes and on youtube as well
yeah and post those pictures of your
tees uh if they haven't gotten there yet
just hang in there they're gonna all be
there we love you guys
and we will uh we'll see you next week
peace